game  in the match between magnus carlson  against shakarya mamajarov and it looked  like it was all headed into a draw when  one horrendous blunder from the azeri  grand master just costs him the game and  magnus pounced  wow  so is he  he's nearing towards that uh goal of  2900  is he  yeah it's a long road but he's certainly  doing well he was already winning  classical rating  before this game in the storm and he  lost to armageddon so his score  didn't look that dominant but he's doing  well in the classical  and winning another white game had he  converted that very good position  against van gaal  could be even better i know he's playing  he's playing very well here just others  vishy especially yeah have also done  great so it hasn't looked  one-sided but this win will put him into  the lead he overtakes fishing i was  going to say he leaped frogs into first  place you know he is there with 12 and a  half